[Musik]
es ist freitagabend herzlich willkommen
bei 48 und freitagabends freue ich mich
besonders dass sie lust auf unsere
politik haben meinen kompetenten gäste
heute abend sind linken politikerin und
senatorin für integration arbeit
soziales in berlin katja kipping mit ihr
möchten wir heute über die aufnahme der
kriegsflüchtlinge sprechen neben ihr der
chef vom bild parlamentsbüro ralf
schuler er ist einer der besten familie
dessen politik soll es des landes und
wird heute bei uns seine 100 tage ampel
bilanz ziehen wie erfolgreich war die
regierung bislang ich bin gespannt an
meiner seite wie jedem bild vilsheim
einer der letzten journalisten im
umkämpften kiew und würde uns heute
exklusiv berichten wie die lage vor ort
ist neben ihnen der stellvertretende
chef der polizeigewerkschaft heilkraut
tag als wir möchten von ihnen heute
wissen von welcher in
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
steht deutschland und kann es sogar sein
dass in den nächsten zwei wochen zwei
millionen menschen zum großteil nach
österreich und deutschland kommen ich
bin sehr gespannt auf die antworten aber
lassen sie uns jetzt zuerst auf die
stadt schauen auf die ganz europa blickt
paul wie gehen die mehr bietet es den
menschen die gehen die menschen mit dem
krieg um und wie ist die versorgungslage
in kiew vor ort
janina die menschen haben sich langsam
an den krieg gewöhnt auch wenn man sich
schwer an einen krieg gewöhnen kann aber
viele wenn sie die sie reden wie gerade
eben auch wieder hören gehen nicht mehr
in den keller weil sie sagen das ist
kein leben wenn wir jedes mal in den
keller rennen finden wir keinen schlaf
mehr können am nächsten tag gar nichts
machen also man gewöhnt sich daran
dadurch steigt natürlich auch die gefahr
also hier in kiew gab es gestern
einschläge in einem wohngebiet in
städten wie mario pohl ist es anders als
in kirchen sind die menschen den ganzen
tag im keller weil es nicht anders ist
weil hunderte bomben dort fallen und die
versorgungslage in kiew die wird
schwieriger tatsächlich man merkt es
dass bestimmte produkte nicht mehr zu
haben sind insbesondere frischeprodukte
die supermärkte leer gekauft sind
allerdings gibt es noch eine verbindung
in den süden der stadt ist es frei da
gibt es freie wege und es gibt auch noch
einen zug der zwischen lemberg und kiew
verkehrt der als flüchtlinge rausbringt
und andererseits menschen hierher kommen
wollen bzw produkte die herkommen wollen
hier einbringt
der russische präsident putin power der
hat heute eine rede gehalten eine
propaganda rede gehalten die
unterbrochen wurde was man aber nicht
gesehen hat was hat es damit auf sich
es gab eine bizarre propaganda show so
muss man es nennen in stadion in moskau
in moskau da wurden viele leute offenbar
auch hin gekappt das habe ich gerade bei
den kollegen von bbc gelesen also arbeit
hat ja eigentlich gar nicht so richtig
hin wollten aber die mehr oder weniger
gedrängt wurden dort hinzugehen und
wladimir putin hat dort eine propaganda
rede gehalten wie man sich bekannte hat
die einheit beschworen russlands in dem
krieg und hat davon gesprochen dass hier
ein genozid verübt werden sollte also
hut sein seine lüge über einen
angeblichen völkermord noch einmal
wiederholt um damit zu rechtfertigen
warum russland dort ist und dann
plötzlich war die rede weg das bild weg
im staatsfernsehen und es ging wieder
von vorne los wo irgendwelche russischen
bands gespielt haben man weiß es bis
jetzt nicht möglicherweise ein
hacker-angriff jemand der bewusst dieses
signal stören wollte jemand der versucht
hat sozusagen wladimir putin zu
schädigen denn das war natürlich eine
seiner wichtigsten reden ja in einer
zeit in der krieg geführt wird und ein
krieg geführt wird der ja für russland
momentan nicht besonders gut aussieht
weil man die ziele die wladimir putin
hat nämlich die eroberung von kiew und
der ukraine in wenigen tagen oder wochen
nicht erreicht
aber paul täuscht der eindruck oder
hatte das ganze eine neue qualität von
inszenatorischen pomp und größenordnung
man kennt ja die regelmäßigen
pressekonferenzen von wladimir putin die
im goldenen gepränge stattfinden wo er
dann die riesigen türen aufgehalten
bekommt und reihen marschiert das hat er
heute jetzt schon wirklich stadion
charakter
vor hintergründen deutschland geschichte
hat man da immer ein gewisses schaudern
solcher stadion geschichten noch zu
kriegszeiten
ist so etwas schon öfter vorgekommen und
das abbrechen wäre jetzt nicht
unwahrscheinlich wenn man davon ausgeht
dass die ganze veranstaltung
zeitversetzt gesendet worden ist so was
gehört eigentlich zum standard in der
sicherheits betonten regime
also ich kann mich an nichts ähnliches
erinnern ralf insbesondere nicht während
des meiden oder des krieges auf der krim
dass man versucht hätte so eine stimmung
zu erzeugen ist zeigt ein bisschen in
welcher ecke putin möglicherweise ist
und was die sicherheitsfrage angeht das
finde ich sehr interessant denn wir und
andere schreiben darüber dass wladimir
putin sich immer wieder in verschiedenen
bunkern versteckt hat dass er den zugang
zur öffentlichkeit kaum sucht also ich
habe mich hier mit ukrainischen
politikern unterhalten da waren einige
davon überzeugt das war nicht der echte
putin das muss einen doppelgänger
gewesen sein das passt nicht zu seinem
auftreten bislang also viele mythen die
wir aber wahrscheinlich nicht lernen
können sondern nur spekulieren können
frau kipping sie verbinden eine
persönliche beziehung mit russland sie
können auch russisch sprechen auf jeden
fall mich in einem interview gelesen
dass sie gesagt haben für den smalltalk
reicht es für eine simultanübersetzung
nicht wahrscheinlich können sie es dann
doch noch etwas besser man geht er eher
ein bisschen zurück mit seinen eigenen
fähigkeiten immer um nicht anzugeben
aber die frage ist natürlich wie
empfinden sie gerade den russischen
präsidenten
also zunächst muss ich sagen mir blutet
natürlich das herz zum einen wenn man
sieht was putin den menschen in der
ukraine antut zum zweiten auch was ich
das wissen was jetzt auch den menschen
in russland passiert ich finde es auch
wichtig dass wir von putins krieg
sprechen und nicht vom krieg der rosen
gegen die ukraine weil wir sehen ja auch
dass auch in russland menschen gibt die
sehr sehr viel riskieren und trotzdem
demonstrieren für ein ende dieses
krieges allein das aussprechen des
wortes krieges ist ja dort mit mehreren
jahren gefängnis inzwischen bedroht und
ich weiß auch inzwischen das leider der
hass den putin seht dass der auch schon
hierzulande niederschlägt und auch in
den schulhöfen niederschlägt also ich
habe neulich mit menschen gesprochen
die russischen gemeinde sind wo ein kind
dessen eines elternteil russisch spricht
dieselbe ukrainische geflüchtete
aufgenommen haben und die auf dem
schulhof angegriffen werden dafür und
für mich ist es so wichtig zum einen in
aller entschiedenheit
putin zu vorurteilen auch zu schauen
inwieweit man da die sanktionen die
wirklich die norma schärfen kann dass
man die kriegsherren im kreml trifft und
zum anderen ganz deutlich zu sagen
niemand wirklich niemand kann was dafür
dass er die selbe sprache wie der
aggressor putin spricht und es sollte
auf keinen fall ein kind auf dem
schulhof dafür büßen müssen
das wirst du vermutlich ganz genauso
sehen paul aber hier die frage an dich
wie groß ist denn die sympathie wladimir
putin in seinem land kann man wirklich
sagen putin ist nicht russland wies die
stimmung
also erstmal bin ich ja in der ukraine
deswegen ist es schwer für mich die
stimmung jetzt in russland zu
beschreiben aber tatsächlich ist es das
auch ein großes diskussionsthema hier
etwas vor kipping dort anspricht und
vorweg geschickt natürlich dürfen kinder
nicht auf schulhöfen deshalb gemobbt
werden und solche fälle da müssen wir
alles gegen thun absolut auf der anderen
seite finde ich ein bisschen einfach nur
von putins krieg zu sprechen und ich
empfinde das auch als falsch wenn wir
peter tiede unserem korrespondenten dort
zu hören wenn ich mir meinungsumfragen
anschauen wenn ich mir anhöre wie
freunde von mir hier in der ukraine mit
menschen in russland telefonieren und
die dann sich als nazis beschimpfen
lassen müssen weil die propaganda dort
im wirkt und wenn wir uns die
meinungsumfragen anschauen dann steht ja
die große mehrheit des russischen volkes
hinter wladimir putin unabhängig davon
haben sie ihn gewählt sie haben sich
auch nicht gegen aufgelehnt als 2014
hier die krim annektiert wurde ganz im
gegenteil da gab es noch mehr jubel also
einfach zu sagen das ist da der böse
diktator und der hat jetzt alle
irgendwie
da unter sich und die können nichts tun
und die tun uns alle so leid und es gäbe
so einen wahnsinnigen widerstand in
russland also bei allem respekt vor
kipping aber den sehe ich noch nicht
natürlich ist es gefährlich auf die
straße zu gehen es gab kleinere proteste
aber das ist jetzt eine massenbewegung
gebe und dass man schon sagen kann dass
ich da alle gegen putin auflehnen das
ist glaube ich nicht der fall das hab
ich ja nicht behauptet herr uns heimat
ich will nur sagen wer in russland sich
entscheidet auf die straße zu gehen und
ich sehe die bilder von den
demonstrationen sind jetzt keine
massendemonstrationen aber muss wissen
wer das macht ihn für sich selber auch
ein großes risiko in kauf das heißt also
da muss es schon eine unglaubliche
überzeugungen geben ansonsten was die
stimmungslage anbelangt in russland die
macht mir natürlich immer auch sorgen
aber schon seit vielen jahren weil ich
eben noch nicht sehe dass es dort
wirklich eine richtig große massen basis
gibt für eine demokratische weltoffene
menschen rechts orientierte alternative
zu putin da das würde ich so beschreiben
als ein großes problem für für die
russische situation aber ich finde immer
nur man darf nicht alle menschen jetzt
mit verhaften natürlich gibt es ein
system putin putins krieg ist übrigens
der titel ihres senders mit noch um das
hier nochmal zu zitieren aber klar wir
sind ganz gut beraten da etwas zu
differenzieren ja putin ist gewählt die
frage ist inwieweit gab es wirklich eine
breite demokratische alternative die
auch eine chance hatte sich bekannt zu
machen unter dem regime von putin frau
kuby gesehen schon 2014 ja auch und 2015
kritik an wladimir putin geübt und dann
russland das gab mit ihrer partei
manchmal nicht so gute laune muss man
sagen habe ich in alten berichten auch
gelesen was waren denn die ersten
alarmzeichen bei ihnen selbst wo sie
gesehen haben okay das ist nicht gut der
weg den er geht
ja was man vielleicht noch mal sagen
muss ich bin ja nach meinem abitur für
ein jahr nach russland gegangen und habe
dort ein freiwilliges soziales jahr
gemacht ich hatte da er mit
italienischen münchen zu tun und jungen
jugendlichen die ich quasi als pädagogen
betreuen sollte und ich habe halt ende
der 90er jahre sankt petersburg erlebt
es eine sehr weltoffene stadt wo immer
so ganz viel in bewegung war und habe
dann über die jahre hinweg gemerkt wie
es in der gesellschaft wieder ein
zusammen 10 gibt es eine wirklich
schwulenfeindlichkeit dann auch
regierungsprogramm wurde und und und und
habe gemerkt wie menschen die ich
getroffen habe bei einem seminar wo es
um sozialproteste gegen meist
sozialkürzungen gab und dann erlebt habe
wie die mieter mehr es gab tage da haben
wir uns nicht getraut rauszugehen zu der
demo die wir gemacht haben weil wir
dachten okay wenn wir rausgehen werde
mir sofort verhaftet dass man so für
mich die alarmzeichen die da schon
geklungen haben für mich war immer
wichtig in der linken sehr deutlich zu
machen dass es bei uns nicht zweierlei
maß geben darf wenn es um menschenrechte
geht und dass man da auch nichts zu
relativieren hat das hat mir nicht nur
freunde gemacht also russia today putins
propagandasender hat dann auch ein patt
roller auf mich geschickt die sehr sage
ich mal als nicht nur freundliche sachen
über mich gesagt haben aber mir war das
wichtig diesen punkt zu setzen und auch
klar zu ziehen dass die linke in dieser
frage steht luksic in karachi james key
ich habe es acht lassen
nicht gerne gelernt auch wegen der
vielen fälle aber 816 fälle gibt es noch
schlimmeres das stimmt uns fällt mir
leichter aber das ist egal das
interessante ist natürlich dass viele
russen diese 90er jahre die sie so als
befreiend erlebt haben gerade
traumatisch in erinnerung haben anfang
an der k s unter jelzin die oligarchen
die zu der zeit stark geworden sind und
sich jeder bedient hat am start das ist
etwas was sowohl putin nach wie vor als
eine nahtoderfahrung des russischen
riesenreiches mit sich herumträgt und
was eben viele leute auch als sehr
unkomfortabel armut alkohol grassierten
nicht zuletzt in der obersten spitze
jetzigen war schwerer alkoholiker
das haben viele nicht so in erinnerung
und aber jetzt sind sie das sind anfang
und mitte der 90er jahre gab eine kurze
phase wurde eine öffnung gab und man
auch der spieler dann geht sie also das
war immer armut wartet man darf der
ernst unterschlagen dass ein gewisser
wunsch nach stärke schon auch in der
russischen gesellschaft tief verankert
ist man schätzt keine führer die sich
schwach zeigen und dann gab es zum
anfang der 90er jahre auch noch ein ganz
anderes problem viele russen dachten
damals wir haben im letzten jahrhundert
zwei kriege gewonnen den ersten und den
zweiten und wir sind eigentlich immer
die liga geblieben am ende zogen die
truppen aus deutschland ab 994 und
deutschland verpflichtete sich ein paar
wohnungen zu bauen das war ein klacks
mit dem für den für das reiche
deutschland aber den lebensstandard der
breiten masse in rossmann hat das alles
nicht verändert und das ist schon auch
ein trauma gegenüber dem westen was man
versucht in einigen kreisen mit
nationalstolz zu puffern und das ist
immer ungut
erleben jetzt auch dass viele menschen
in dieses land kommen nicht aus russland
vor allem aus der ukraine und anderen
staaten erleben sie denn da jetzt auch
diesen russen hass oder den hass auf die
russische gesellschaft nein also bislang
bis dann kann man das auch nur schwer
differenzieren weil die meisten mit
denen wir polizeilicher zu tun haben die
hier ankommen in deutschland sind halt
ukrainer oder haben auch einen
ukrainischen hintergrund also das kann
ich so nicht bestätigen mehr macht das
aber auch große sorge dass ihm gerade
gerade erzählt hat wenn es tatsächlich
schon soweit ist dass in den schulen und
in den kindergärten dort aus den
elternhäusern raus ukrainische und
russische kinder sich da schon auf
deutsch gesagt in die wolle bekommen
dann müssen in jeder senatsverwaltung
alle alarmglocken schellen und man muss
da mit prävention jetzt darauf reagieren
und nicht warten bis da bis da schlimmes
in den schulen passiert aber es gab ja
sogar brandanschlägen in berlin auf
einer londoner schule eine bilinguale
schule also das ist schon fall wohl auch
inzwischen der staatsschutz ermitteln
muss und frau kipping sie haben uns ja
auch das thema kriegsflüchtlinge heute
abend mitgebracht und das ist doch eine
gute überleitung zu ihrer these
ja also ich
befürchte wir befinden uns am anfang der
wahrscheinlich größten fluchtbewegung in
europa seit ende des zweiten weltkriegs
wir erleben dass in berlin im besonderen
mal natürlich berlin für die kriegs
geflüchteten aus der ukraine das tor zu
westeuropa ist wir sind ja jetzt seit
rund drei wochen auch in vorleistung
gegangen für die gesamte bundesrepublik
haben quasi als kleine stadt als
kleinstadt land die menschen aufgenommen
und dann uns bemüht eine bundesweite
verteilung erst mal selbstständig und
auf freiwilliger basis in die wege zu
leiten und jetzt sagen die große
herausforderung die ich mein team die
ehrenamtlichen erleben ist im folgendes
man hat das einerseits jeden tag mit
sehr großen zahlen zu tun die mit vollen
bussen vollen zügen schubweise ankommen
bis tief in die nacht und sogleich hat
man es nicht nur mit großen zahlen zu
tun sondern mit ganz konkreten menschen
die alle auch schreckliche geschichten
haben als es kommen viele alleinreisende
mütter mit kindern inzwischen auch mehr
mütter die noch andere kinder mitnehmen
weil die eltern nicht fliehen können
aber sagen dann nimmst du noch die
freundin vom kind mit die kinder haben
teilweise ein haustier mit dass er so
das letzte überbleibsel von der heimat
was man eigentlich nach veterinär
gesichtspunkten erstmal qualität
schicken kann aber wer will ein kind
schon den hasen wegnehmen was karten
vater zurückgelassen hat im
schützengraben wir haben zunehmend mehr
menschen mit behinderungen
pflegebedürftige also das sind menschen
mit ganz besonderen bedarf die hunde
besondere unterstützung brauchen wir
zugleich seine großen mengen und dem
gerecht zu werden das zu organisieren
und dann auch jeweils die individuellen
bedarfe zu sehen das ist eine verdammt
große herausforderung und wir tun das
alles in dem wissen dass wir erst am
anfang sind also vor uns liegt noch ein
marathon und wir laufen jeden tag ein
sprint und kriegen sie sprechen mir aus
der seele ich warne vor
oder seit wochen eigentlich schon davor
seit kriegsbeginn vor dass wir es hier
mit einem massenphänomen zu tun bekommen
und das berlin wahrscheinlich dass
einfalltor zunächst mal ist mag auch der
tatsache geschuldet sein berlin ist arm
aber sexy meine frage kleber glaube ich
eher an der geographischen lage und den
magnet für meine frage ist jetzt an sie
konkret was hat denn der berliner senat
als er als er gemerkt hat wir kriegen
hier ein problem ein mittelschweres
problem nicht nur am hauptbahnhof
sondern in ganz berlin unternommen der
bundesregierung gegenüber
und an hilfen gebeten beziehungsweise
konkrete maßnahmen von der
bundesregierung gefordert wie man diese
zuströme kanalisieren und letztendlich
auch in den griff bekommen kann
also wir haben ein großteil meiner
arbeitszeit und energie aber auch von
anderen senatsmitglieder auch von der
regierenden bürgermeisterin ist auch da
drauf gegangen wirklich dem buch den
bund wachzurütteln und zu sagen leute
wir haben es hier wirklich mit einer
grossen flucht bewegung zu tun und es
werden womöglich noch mehr kommen wenn
der krieg weitergeht wir haben
persönlich angerufen zum hörer gegriffen
haben letztlich auch in amtshilfe
ersuchen an die bundesregierung gestellt
haben in den verschiedensten schalten
immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
es gibt hier ein problem ich weiß als
ich schon in der an die öffentlichkeit
gegangen wir haben hier wahrscheinlich
einfach eine größten fluchtbewegung hat
das bank noch erzählt in den medien naja
sind doch bisher nur 5000 gekommen da
hatten wir schon am bahnhof im
hauptbahnhof in berlin jeden tag 10.000
ankünfte also da haben wir sehr viel
unternommen ich muss sagen zum glück ist
der bund jetzt auch wach geworden und es
beginnt jetzt hoffentlich die
verbindliche bundesweite verteilung an
diesem wochenende wir mussten das
teilweise über brücken und haben
bilateral mit anderen bundesländern uns
verständigt um das hinzubekommen aber
die ganze situation wurde natürlich
dadurch erschwert dass wir das system
der doppelten freiwilligkeit haben also
wir können zwar die leute registrieren
aufnehmen und dann entscheidet das easy
systemen welches bundesland kommen die
aber die anderen die aufnehmen
bundesländer sind frei zu sagen
geschicken die wieder zurück haben sie
ihre chefin pro kiefer mal ganz
vorsichtig den tipp gegeben dass die
bundesinnenminister in der gleichen
partei angehört da braucht überhaupt
kein tipp also muss sagen wir haben uns
erst jetzt in den letzten monaten
kennengelernt aber vgh hat von anfang an
die brisanz der lage erkannt hat sich
unglaublich ins zeug gelegt hat profil
hat die hat die verschiedenen bin jetzt
nicht die regierungssprecherin der
bundesregierung genau nicht in der spd
aber ich kann nur sagen die regierende
bürgermeisterin von berlin hat sich echt
ins zeug gelegt und hat auch permanent
die verschiedensten anrufe getätigt und
schritte in die wege geleitet um den
bund zu sensibilisieren mit was von
herausforderung wir es hier zu tun haben
hertha hat der stellvertretende
vorsitzende polizeigewerkschaft sie
wissen also genau wo es bei der polizei
brennt wie die polizei bad aussee wenn
sie es hören die herausforderung vor der
bestehen ich habe eine ganz pragmatische
frage darüber mein letzten tage viel
debattiert können sie eigentlich
beziffern wie viele der ankommenden
flüchtlinge ukrainer sind nein wir
können nur das beziffern was wir
feststellen im rahmen der der momentan
schleierfahndung also überwachung der
grenze zu polen mir liegen zahlen vor
die sind jetzt bei 200.000 seiten flucht
beginnen und da drunter ungefähr zwölf
bis 15.000 nicht die ukraine das sind
aber alles keine repräsentativen zahlen
weil wir wie gesagt an unserer an
unserer eigentlichen kernaufgabe
momentan noch auch durch die gleiche
bundesregierung gehindert werden wir
werden ist nie schaffen aktuelle zahlen
zu erheben das geht höchstens retro grad
war ja die die die menschen die kommen
aus der ukraine die freiheit haben
gottseidank sich in deutschland wo auch
immer registrieren zu lassen das heißt
werden immer tage wochen unter umständen
sogar monate vergehen bis wir genau
wissen wie viele menschen sind nach
deutschland gekommen dann wissen wir
noch nicht mal genau wer also das ist
eine hochdramatische langen ich kann nur
daran erinnern ich hatte ich hatte
bereits im herbst auch in diesem in
diesem kreis gewarnt vor der vor der
entwicklung gerade was die was die
fluchtrichtung aus belarus angeht und es
ist bitter das ist wirklich bitter dass
bis heute offensichtlich eine
unbelehrbarkeit unserer bundesregierung
davor herrscht und schlichtweg
fachexperten aus dem bereich der
bundespolizei nicht gehört umso
erstaunlicher ist es dass die
bundesinnenminister in dem spiegel jetzt
in der neuen ausgabe gesagt hat ist ein
sechs prozent nicht ukraine unter den
ankommenden wenn man weiß dass nur
stichproben kontrolliert werden ist die
hochrechnung auf präzise prozentzahlen
mathematischen ziemliches kunststücke
und sie hat von 10.000 doppelstaatler
beziehungsweise nicht ukraine
angesprochen also aus einer stichprobe
präzise zahlen hochzurechnen finde ich
eine sehr interessante geschichte ich
habe so ein bisschen den eindruck dass
da eine falsche fährte gelegt wird
selbstverständlich könnte man
registrieren müsste man allerdings an
den grenzen auch kontrollen einführen
und die müsste man von der eu
notifizieren lassen was allerdings wohl
in der gegenwärtigen situation kein
problem wäre wir bleiben jetzt auch
direkt bei dem thema was das weil sie
auch gleich vorstellen hätte das worin
die polizeiliche unterstützung braucht
oder warum sie einfach ihre arbeit
machen wenn ich würde aber vor noch
einmal ganz kurz gerne zusammen kirsch
alten paul wir sprechen über flüchtlinge
die kommen es gibt aber auch menschen
die sich klar entscheiden sagt mir bitte
wenn ich falsch liege dass sie in kiew
und in der ukraine bleiben werden
was hat es damit auf sich wie viele
werden bleiben und wie viele werden
kämpfen bis die lage vor ort und wurde
beispielsweise auch schon energie
rationiert in kiew
das ist wirklich das besonders
erstaunliche muss man sagen auch heute
wieder gab es einen schweren angriff in
einem wohnviertel
auch eine schule ist ein kindergarten wo
mehrere kinder verletzt wurden mehrere
menschen verletzt wurden ein mann ist
gestorben und ich war dort in einer
völlig zerbombten wohnung bei einer frau
ludmilla heißt sie hat mir gezeigt wo
sie normalerweise geschlafen hätte zum
glück waren sie an dem abend bei ihrer
tochter im keller und hat sich vor
diesen angriffen geschützt deswegen war
sie noch am leben und hinterher habe ich
sie gefragt warum bleibt dir eigentlich
hier warum setzt ihr euch diesem risiko
aus und die frauen die dort standen die
haben mir gesagt warum sollen wir gehen
das ist unsere stadt und so lange es
irgendwie möglich ist werden wir hier
bleiben was sollen wir denn in
deutschland wo sind wir denn dann da wo
wir sind wir untergebracht nein wir
wollen hierbleiben und viele haben
einfach aus sorge um ihre verwandten um
die eltern um die kinder die ganz
klassischen dinge ich glaube solange
eine stadt nicht so aussieht wie zum
beispiel mario pool oder eine stadt
nicht so aussieht wie ihre pin oder
botschafter sind die vororte von kia
fonds auch ein dauerbeschuss gibt die
menschen werden versuchen immer weiter
hier zu bleiben ist noch zwei millionen
menschen in kiew vor dem krieg waren es
fast 4 witali klitschko sagt die zahl
der leute geht er nach oben und die
sozusagen männer die ihre frauen und
kinder in den westen gebracht haben
kommen jetzt zurück um die stadt zu
verteidigen das ist tatsächlich etwas
erstaunlich ist aber es wird sich
natürlich ändern wenn es hier weitere
flächenbombardements gibt also wenn
wladimir putin noch mehr flieger
einsetzen würde wobei die luftabwehr in
kiew zum beispiel besser ist als in
mario pohl auf die raketenabwehr aber
wenn er wenn ich jetzt mal mario pohl
mit aleppo vergleiche wenn man sagt das
sind 80 prozent der zivilen gebäude
zerstört wenn er ähnliche szenen krk
machen würde dann gäbe es natürlich auch
einem massenflucht von daher müssen wir
alles alles tun um wladimir putin
davon abzuhalten mit noch steht aus
meiner sicht mit noch stärkeren
sanktionen
mit mehr waffenlieferungen wir haben
jetzt gerade gelesen eine meldung aus
der welt am sonntag dass von den
versprochenen hilfslieferungen den
versprochenen waffen aus deutschland
nicht mal die hälfte geliefert wurden
und das sind so dinge wo man sich dann
schon an kopf hast und denkt ihr redet
die ganze zeit über die ukraine aber
beim umsetzen und der tatkraft dafür
gibt's nicht
danke für deine einschätzung von diesen
wichtigen appell wir fünf sind gleich
einer kurzen unterbrechung wieder für
sie da dann mit dem appell von heiko
teggatz dass die politik einfach die
polizei im job machen lassen soll bis
gleich wissen gleich wieder zurück
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bild
das box highlight live bei bild
[Musik]
felix sturm auf dem weg zum
weltmeistertitel
der kampf gegen israel
willkommen zurück
die boxnacht am
26 märz bei bild dieser sendung wird
präsentiert von governor of poker 3 die
gratis poker app fürs handy
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer
zurück es ist freitagabend schön dass
sie dabei sind auch noch nach der
werbung und meine gäste heute abend sind
linke politikerin katja kipping an
meiner seite auch bild parlamentsbüro
leiter ralf schuler der bild vize paul
ronzheimer live aus kiew und
zugeschaltet und der stellvertretende
vorsitz der polizeigewerkschaft rita
katz und mit dem machen wir jetzt direkt
weiter den er kein appell mitgebracht
der sehr eindringlich ist vor allem auch
mit blick auf die flüchtlingsfrage
hunderttausende menschen flüchten
tagtäglich aus der ukraine vor krieg und
zerstörung
ungefähr zehn bis zwölftausend menschen
erreichen nach tagen der flucht die
grenze zwischen polen und deutschland
die bundespolizei ist von beginn an von
kriegsbeginn an also seit dem 24 februar
auf diese flucht bewegung eingestellt
leider fehlt es bis heute an politischen
entscheidungen ob die bundespolizei
flächendeckend an der polnischen und
tschechischen grenze kontrollstellen
betreiben darf oder nicht mein appell an
die bundesregierung auch von hier noch
mal lasst uns endlich unseren job machen
die bundespolizei kann dass es ist eine
kernaufgabe die auch in unserer
verfassung niedergeschrieben ist das
thema grenzschutz und ich bitte noch
einmal herzlich darum um ordnung in
diese flüchtlingsströme zu bekommen
lasst die bundespolizei dort an der
grenze kontrollieren
also die bundespolizei ist sowohl
technisch als auch personell so
ausgestattet dass innerhalb kürzester
zeit an den grenzübergängen an den
autobahnen bundesstraßen
gebäude errichtet werden könnten
container aufgestellt werden könnten
gemeinsam mit dem thw beheizte zelte
caterer rotes kreuz test spuren für für
für kohler infektion selbst impfstraßen
könnten dort errichtet werden die
menschen hätten dort eine anlaufstelle
direkt an der grenze oder auf den
bahnhöfen in deutschland und könnten
dort professionell behördlich erfasst
werden und dann auch unter staatlicher
aufsicht weiter verteilt werden ohne
jetzt gefahr laufen dazu müssen in die
hände privater
helfer zu geraten die ja auch hier in
berlin auf dem hauptbahnhof ihre ehre
schildchen hoch halten und vielleicht
etwas ganz anderes im schilde führen als
tatsächlich helfen zu wollen das ist der
status wie es sein könnte wie sie es
gerne machen würden auch im blick auf
den grenzschutz beim blick aufs konto
aktuell betreibt die bundespolizei
sieben sogenannte bearbeitung straßen
das sind meistens gebäude lagerhallen
leerstehende lagerhallen die wir so
umgebaut haben dass wir dort menschen
teilweise mit einer kapazität von bis zu
650 im durchlauf sozusagen unterbringen
könnten für die registrierung leider ist
es so dass wir derzeit am beispiel
frankfurt oder nur die ankommenden züge
genauer beleuchten und die menschen dort
aus den aus den zügen letztendlich in
diesem in diese einrichtung bringen
können was uns nur sehr sehr sehr
oberflächlich gelingt ist die
bestreifung der grenze also auch die die
nachschau an den grenzübergangsstellen
an den autobahn an den bundesstraßen und
auch an den kreisstraßen die von polen
nach deutschland führen das verzerrt
natürlich das bild und erschwert den
kommunen und den ländern dann
logischerweise auch die die erfassung
also ich sag ja immer wir wollen ja um
gottes willen niemanden an dieser grenze
zurückweisen das sind menschen die
wirklich schwer traumatisiert
kriegsflüchtlinge in unmittelbarer nähe
nach europa kommen aber wir müssen doch
wissen wer in unser land kommt und es
ist auch nicht auszuschließen dass sich
unter diese ströme auch personen mission
die eben nicht
kriegsflüchtlinge sind sondern was ganz
anderes im schilde führen und wir laufen
gefahr
die kontrolle nicht nur zu verlieren wir
haben seit 2005 in dem fall sowieso
nicht mehr aber wir laufen nicht gefahr
dass zu einem großen sicherheitsrisiko
in deutschland werden zu lassen ich
würde es ganz gerne mal diese diesen
misstrauens verdacht ausräumen wollen
der da immer mit im spiel ist wer
kontrolliert der ist doch an abwehr
januar interessiert oder tritt den
migranten mit misstrauen entgegen es
geht natürlich auch darum zu wissen wer
braucht besondere hilfe wer kann wohin
verteilt werden wer war vorhin hier und
ist demnächst in kaiserslautern wie
viele kinder muss man beschulen wer
braucht psychologische unterstützung die
polen machen das mustergültig an ihrer
grenze und registrieren auch diejenigen
die leute abholen von dort so dass man
eigentlich genau weiß wer wo sein müsste
das hat nichts mit überwachungsstaat zu
tun das ist glaube ich auch für die
soziale betreuung eigentlich ganz
hilfreich wenn man das nachvollziehen
kann oder sehen sie das anders kann ja
mal sagen wie wir das in berlin machen
wir konnten ja noch nicht warten das ist
ein perfektes system bundesweit gibt
sondern die menschen waren da und wir
mussten handeln und wir hatten null
vorlauf also am donnerstag begann der
krieg am freitag habe ich entschieden wo
wir sie aufnehmen und am samstag waren
die ersten da und von da an gab es einen
kalt statt vier ehrenamtlichen
verwaltungs mitarbeitende bei uns ist es
jetzt so wir haben unter zum einen erst
mal jede nacht sicherstellen müssen dass
die menschen einfach ein dach über den
kopf bekommen und was zu essen das ist
die unten im übrigen ein bisschen
medizinische notversorgung und die
notfälle nehmen deutlich zu und was wir
jetzt plan ist am ehemaligen flughafen
tegel ein ankunft zentrum wo alle
menschen die in berlin ankommt mit
bussen hingefahren werden wo dann und in
einem zusammenspiel von ehrenamtlichen
helfenden hilfsorganisation
verwaltungsmitarbeitern bis hin zur
bundespolizei das lf arbeitet mit der
ein bisschen bundeswehr bundeswehr es
mit dem einsatz und in das lf bei uns
das landesamt arbeitet mit der polizei
zusammen also in diesem zusammenspiel
ehrenamtliche aktivisten über verwaltung
bis hin zur bundeswehr findet dort habe
deine augen nahm er eingehender machen
sie dann nicht genau das warum
eigentlich hat es heute abend bittet sie
als politik reißen ist an sich wo er
sagt hertha sagt die bundespolizei
könnte ist doch jetzt schon regeln und
so habe ich bin aber ich bin also
erstmal die leute waren in berlin und
ich muss mich um sie kümmern und ich
sehe in der befehlskette nicht über den
platz und darf der bundespolizei keine
anweisung geben ich kann nur mit viel
sozusagen einsatz in berlin ins system
machen wie wir damit umgehen mit den
menschen die in berlin sondern ich finde
dass wir für tegel entwickelt haben ist
eine gute sache man muss also ich finde
auch immer dafür dass es ein system gibt
wo ehrenamtliche auch mit integriert
werden weil es gibt in der bevölkerung
eine enorme hilfe wirtschaft die ist
glaube ich auch sehr sehr wichtig auch
dass man die welle der solidarität
weiter trägt und es ist den menschen
noch ein bedürfnis sich da einzubringen
und gesagt wir machen das so dass wir
als allererstes voran schalten wollen
die bundesweite verteilung und die die
in berlin bleiben die bekommen eine
registrierung da gibt es einen tegel ne
erste unterkunft protest und das
brauchst ja auch immer medizinischen
check möglichst bis nach am besten das
impfzentrum nebenan dass man dann
vielleicht nicht in der ersten nacht
wenn die menschen nach einer
dramatischen flucht sind kam jetzt nicht
gleich mit der impfung kommen aber am
zweiten und dritten tag kann man das
machen dann gibt es auch ein paar
hinweise weil von der gewerkschaft was
man hier für arbeitsrecht hat dass man
da nicht irgendwie leuten in die hände
fällt die die im not jetzt ausnutzen und
das alles wird dann dort mit organisiert
das kann man bestimmt auch anders machen
hat nun ist weit verteilt an der grenze
ich bin jetzt in berlin mit einer
situation konfrontiert gewesen und uns
war es wichtig im zusammenspiel aller
akteure da zum einen was ordnungsgemäße
auf die bahn zu setzen aber auch muss
ich sagen zuallererst zu schauen das
sind menschen die am schreckliches
hinter sich und da müssen für dinge
geklärt werden für die bett essen
medizinische versorgung und ich
beobachte seit einigen tagen dass die
zahl der menschen die schwer
pflegebedürftig sind wir haben ganze
busse voll von blinden weil die einer
blinden einrichtungen sind wir haben
ganze waisenhäuser ein jüdisches weißen
haus mit 120 kindern was gekommen ist
also immer auch gruppen für die man dann
noch mal eine ganz spezielle unterkunft
und entsprechende unterstützung braucht
also mit ich verstehe dass sie sich mit
der sicherheitsfrage beschäftigen ich
musste mich zum beispiel mit fragen
beschäftigen wie da kommen er 100
ukrainische gehörlose das heißt man
braucht ein gebärdendolmetscher er muss
aber behördensprache ukrainisch und
deutsch sind noch mal unterschiedlich
das heißt da brauchst du noch mal zwei
die die sprache können das sind so ein
problem mit dem wir uns auch noch
beschäftigen und sie haben es jetzt ja
gerade gesagt ich beleuchte natürlich
die sich
genau aber das ist ja eigentlich nicht
ihr job die sicherheitsaspekte als
berliner senat jetzt auch mal zu
übernehmen werden die bundespolizei das
schon hätte machen können
wenn nämlich unsere bundesregierung die
grenzen zu polen und der tschechischen
republik notifiziert hatte wir wären wie
gesagt in der lage gewesen innerhalb
kürzester zeit sowohl materiell als auch
personell diese aufgabe zu übernehmen
nicht nur an den grenzen sondern auch an
den bahnhöfen wenn ich überlege dass ein
zug voll mit mitmenschen hier in berlin
auf dem hauptbahnhof einfährt und nicht
einmal das gleis der bahnsteig separiert
die türen gehen auf die menschen steigen
aus in einer völlig fremden stadt völlig
traumatisiert die wissen überhaupt gar
nicht wo sie hin sollen jetzt können sie
natürlich sagen ja da sind freiwillige
helfer vor ort
wo es was ist es dann auch vermeiden und
mitarbeiter fort aber wir
haben na ja also ich war immer die
polizei ist am limit also so viele
kräfte wie wir in berlin im einsatz an
wenn sie das ist alles die bundespolizei
machen will
das vorhaben plädiert frau kipping
damals ich bin gar nicht dagegen
gestimmt punkte wo wir politisch echten
fans haben jetzt will ich aber nur sagen
dieser situation was er so dass meine
sozialabteilung ein krisenstab mit der
bundespolizei kooperiert hat weil wir
hatten flugblätter wo auf ukrainisch
draufstand wo die leute hinkommen sollen
die haben wir natürlich als aller art
zusammen bundes bundespolizei und bahn
geschickt dass die die im zug verteilt
denn die einzigen von denen wir dann
irgendwann mal zahlen hatten wie die
züge voll sinn war entweder deutsche
bahn oder die die bundespolizei und wir
mussten jede nacht mit einer total
flexiblen zahl plan wie viele menschen
kommen irgendwann hatte man den
erfahrungswert wenn ein zug mit 1000
menschen ankommt so und so viel gehen zu
privaten um so und so viel muss man sich
dann sofort kümmern also wir haben hier
echt also wir mussten dass sie ausbaden
dass die zahlen nämlich so dass sage ja
aber das ist doch chaotisch es ist doch
chaotisch man kann doch man kann doch
verdammt noch mal von einem rechtsstaat
verlangen dass das geordnet passiert und
jetzt sind wir schon im 22 tag des krieg
ist und der ankommenden menschen aus
diesen krieg und tatsächlich unternommen
also also es tut mir leid das sagen zu
müssen ich empfinde das nicht so dass
der staat jemals die kontrolle über
diese lage sicherheitspolitische lage
hat es eine abschließende frage an der
tiger zu ihrer these der soziologe genau
es halt gesagt dass es sein kann dass
der nächsten zwei wochen damit ich jetzt
nicht falsch die tiere zwei millionen
menschen zum größten teil nach
österreich in deutschland kommt zwei
millionen ist das möglich denkbar ist
dass man hat es ja gerade beschrieben
denn wenn der beschuss aus kiew noch
weitergeht und und und irgendwo müssen
die menschen dann ja hin und wenn es
wenn die luft in der ukraine noch dünner
wird und die und die russische armee
dort auch nur noch mehr land gewinne zu
verzeichnen haben da selbstverständlich
das ist nicht utopisch
also deswegen hier nochmal ihr appell
wenn sie heute mit so viel nach gebracht
haben die politik soll endlich die
polizei sich darum kümmern lassen mein
thema ist heute etwas anderer natur
es ist ein thema was mich auch vor allem
mit russland beschäftigt mit blick auf
russland mein thema heute abend ist
nämlich russland braucht den
europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte russland wurde nämlich
aus dem europarat ausgeschlossen
145 millionen russland russen sind die
leidtragenden in bleibt der zugang zum
europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte künftig verwehrt der
grund der zugang zu diesem gericht ist
ein die mitgliedschaft im europarat
verbunden hier muss man wissen aus
russland stammen mit abstand die meisten
klagen am europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte
oft ist dieser die letzte hoffnung für
justizopfer die nzz titelte einst der
menschenrechtsgerichtshof ist der
stachel im fleisch der russischen justiz
hoffen wir dass es bald wieder sein kann
und auch wenn russland die urteile des
menschenrechtsgerichts hof in der
vergangenheit nicht wirklich ernst
genommen hat waren sie immer doch ein
signal an russland auch an die menschen
vor ort wir hören hin wir sehen euch
aber natürlich weiß ich dass es richtig
war russland aus dem europarat
auszuschließen und damit leider auch aus
dem menschengerichtshof ich möchte
trotzdem heute die debatte darüber
führen wie man vielleicht dennoch etwas
für die russische bevölkerung möglich
machen könnte und da würde ich direkt
ein paar ronzheimer in kiew weitergeben
was er zu meiner these deckt
also ich denke zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
hilft in jederlei hinsicht nur härte und
der ausschluss ist vollkommen
gerechtfertigt hätte aus meiner sicht
schon viel früher passieren müssen und
in wahrheit sind wir da bei der frage
die wir schon vorhin diskutiert haben
inwieweit ist sozusagen eine gesamte
bevölkerung ich finde ich sagen haftbar
aber mitverantwortlich oder
verantwortlich für das was die regierung
tut und da bin ich doch der meinung dass
viele menschen offenbar dort nicht
verstanden haben was in der ukraine
passiert noch einmal es werden jeden tag
hunderte bomben auf dieses land
von putin fallengelassen raketen
abgefeuert und jeden tag sterben
unschuldige menschen und wir haben dann
heute gesehen diese jubel arie für
wladimir putin wir sehen umfragewerte wo
die bevölkerung weiterhin an ihn glaubt
und sagt hier in der ukraine wo ich bin
sind gerade nazis also ich glaube wir
müssen und da gehört die frage wen er
dazu die duh diskutiert hast in jederlei
hinsicht deutlich machen dass das was
vladimir putin tut
dass das verbrecherisch ist und leider
gottes gehören solche maßnahmen dazu
naja ich bin da etwas zwiegespalten es
ist im wesentlichen ja einen gesprächs
gremium russland ist da schon einmal
suspendiert worden nach der krim
annexion
interessanterweise ist dann auf drängen
russlands hinterher einen passus
eingefügt worden in die statuten dass
eine suspendierung nicht mehr möglich
ist jetzt kann man eigentlich nur noch
raus werfen und nichts anderes
andererseits muss man eben auch sagen
der europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte ist eigentlich im grunde
genommen die letzte hoffnung die einen
regimekritiker in russland noch haben
kann soweit ich gehört habe hat russland
sogar eine entschädigungssumme an
navalny gezahlt ich weiß nicht ob das
stimmt es wird auch nicht viel gewesen
sein
insofern ist es immer schwierig wir
haben ja auch den un-menschenrechtsrat
wo wie so ziemlich alle schurken dieser
welt mit drin sitzen zum teil schwer
schwere frauen rechtsverletzer im
gleichstellungs komitee das ist alles
ein bisschen
zum teil widersinnig andererseits muss
man sagen okay wenn man irgendetwas
damit bewegen kann dann sollte man es
versuchen die vereinten nationen sind ja
auch ein klub der nicht irgendjemanden
ausschließt sonst müsste man eigentlich
russland rauswerfen wird wahrscheinlich
nicht passieren aber dann könnte es ja
selbst veto einlegen ich bin immer ein
bisschen im zweifel ob sinn und nutzen
von symbolischen gesten da einem guten
verhältnis stehen die ächtung des
russischen krieges ist glaube ich auf
allen ebenen von den vereinten nationen
bis runter nach europa und in einzelne
nationen bis jetzt deutlich geworden
wenn es irgend etwas helfen kann wäre
ich dafür russland zumindest weiter dem
europäischen gerichtshof zu unterstellen
ob das lässt sich jetzt glaube ich aber
nicht mehr reparieren insofern ist das
verschüttete milch
der hof sanktionen mit voller härte
würde ich immer ein stimmen aber die
frage ist ja ob der ausschluss aus
diesen europäischen gerichtshof jetzt
putin und seine freunde trifft oder ob
die nicht vielleicht sogar froh sind
dass sie das los sind weil ihr das
sowieso suspekt war als instanz und dass
er anderen geholfen hat also ich meine
es stimmt schon es ist passiert und es
wird vielleicht nicht mehr zurückzuholen
seien aber die frage sehr gibt es
nochmal sanktionen die die viel
zielgerichteter treffen also
luxusyachten der oligarchischen
beschlagnahme zuschauen bei den
immobilien wenn die in der hand von
seinem putins freunden sind kann man
dort nicht stärker eingehen ich weiß
dass es verdammt schwierig das
nachzuweisen dass die wirklich die in
haben und den hingerichtet auch die
sanktion zu verteilen ist natürlich auch
nicht so ein wer aber zum beispiel dort
wo wir in zugriff hätten auf luxus
jahren oder immobilien dies in hier in
europa gibt dass wir die beschlagnahme
das ist dass die fiskalische forensik
hochproblematisch nachzuweisen weil die
sind ja geschickt und schicken dann oft
mittelsmänner vor aber das wäre nochmal
ansetzt wo ich sagen würde darunter
leitet kein einziger
menschenrechtsaktivistin russland aber
es könnte ihn und sein umfeld viel
stärker treffen wir sind ja als
rechtsstaaten leider immer etwas
unschönen situation das ganze
legalisieren zu müssen dann halt nicht
einfach zu sagen du hast auch damals mit
putin gekuschelt jetzt aber raus das
macht alles immer etwas schwieriger
listen zu benennen es gibt ja auch für
die playoffs für ausweisung gibt es ja
auch eine liste der unerwünschten person
und und bei den immobilien steht
meistens allerdings nicht gerade mut ihn
im grundbuch und auch bei den grafen
sind irgendwelche fragen das macht es
also für uns immer etwas schwieriger
auch wenn jeder weiß dass es dem
imperium zuzuordnen ist es ist bei uns
meistens schwieriger leute solche leute
zu verfolgen und auch sippenhaft ist ja
bei uns nicht wirklich
gang und gäbe also auch angehörige zu
belangen da tun sich auch rechtsstaaten
dann immer schwer ich will dass damit
jetzt nicht recht nicht rechtfertigen
das problem ist einfach wenn wir uns an
unsere eigenen hohen standards halten
sind uns die hände gebunden als ein
willkür herrscher wie putin
paul an dieser stelle nochmals zu dir
nach kiew du verbringst auch viel zeit
mit den klitschko brüder mit dem
bürgermeister von kiew vitali klitschko
was fordern die klitschko-brüder was
fordern die menschen in der ukraine was
wir tun können
ja ich komm tatsächlich gerade von ihm
und habe mit ihm ein interview geführt
beziehungsweise war dort das ist eine
immer noch absurde szenerie die beiden
brüder immer zusammen man muss wissen
vor war es so dass vitali seinen job als
bürgermeister hatte und wladimir ist
sozusagen zwischen hamburg zwischen usa
und kiew hin und her gewandert jetzt
sieht man sie an verschiedenen orten
immer geheimen orten natürlich immer
zusammen irgendwie rührend auch zu sehen
die beiden wie sie sich unterstützen
aber häufig auch in voller kampfmontur
sozusagen also zumindest mit
schutzwesten
sind dann dort vor den häusern die
völlig zerstört sind und man sieht ihnen
an wie sehr ihn das wie sehr sie das
mitnimmt zusehen wie ihre heimatstadt
hier nach und nach weiter kaputt gebombt
wird
also das wird
also dass das sieht man wirklich im
gesicht von tag zu tag wie sehr die
beiden das zeichnet was deutschland
angeht da fragen sie mich immer wie
bestimmte dinge wie das eigentlich sein
kann also da ging es auch um die debatte
tatsächlich die wir hier schon geführt
haben nämlich olaf scholz hat ja auch in
einem tweet klar gemacht dass das alles
nur ausschließlich putins krieg sei und
man sozusagen da nicht die russen
insgesamt kritisieren soll und das sieht
man hier in kiew sehr an dass man sagt
ja wo sind denn diejenigen die sich
wirklich distanzieren wo ist denn die
welle der solidarität mit der ukraine
das ist das eine das zweite was sie sehr
sehr ärgert ist die deutsche
zurückhaltung weiterhin bei den
sanktionen da gibt es ja auch berichte
dass deutschland wieder dafür
verantwortlich ist dass bestimmte
sanktion nicht umgesetzt wurden damit
meine ich jetzt nicht öl und gas im
wagen sondern auch einzelne weitere und
dann wieder für ausnahmen gesorgt hat
die skepsis ist groß was deutschland
angeht in der ukraine das muss man ganz
klar sagen und das hat vor allem mit den
letzten jahren zu tun und immer wieder
mit den aussagen da ein nord stream zwei
die just verbleiben das hat nichts mit
putin zu tun also die unentschlossenheit
und die putin liebe vieler politiker
lange zeit die sorgt sie dafür dass man
doch sehr skeptisch nach deutschland
schaut
sehr skeptisch nach deutschland schaut
und wir schauen jetzt mal wie
parlamentschef parlamentsbüro chef von
wildreis schule auf die 100 tage der
regierung bislang schaut ja jetzt kommen
wieder ins deutsche kleinen kleinen
zurück aus der großen weltpolitik die
ampelkoalition hat jetzt ihren 100 tage
geburtstag gefeiert ich weiß nicht ob
irgendjemand von ihnen da draußen die
party mitbekommen hat die korken haben
nicht allzu laut geknallt nun kann man
sich fragen ob die was haben sie gemacht
in der zeit wie geht es ihnen eigentlich
das erste große projekt der ampel die
impfpflicht hat keine eigene mehrheit in
den der drei-parteien-koalition
die aufrüstung die olaf scholz großartig
verkündet hat da haben die grünen auch
sehr schnell geguckt ich bin nicht
sicher ob die mehrheit dafür steht und
die verlängerung von kohle und atomkraft
als ausdruck der eigenen die
souveränität scheint mir auch nicht
wirklich ein lieblingsprojekt jetzt in
der ampel zu sein mit anderen worten
union muss bei vielen projekten helfen
das ist kein ausweis von besonders
stabilen machtverhältnissen läuft für
die ampel könnte man sagen die
bundesverteidigungsministerium übt sich
vor allen dingen der waffen werden ab
dann hört man und sieht man relativ
wenig aber sie hat ja immerhin 5000
helme geliefert das lässt sich ja auch
sehen die bundesumweltministerin hat er
dem wir erinnern uns bei den
festgelegten endzeit klima freundin
gemeint dass ziviler ungehorsam aber
dazu gehören muss hat sie dann später
wieder ein bisschen zurückgenommen und
bundes notarzt karl lauterbach rennt mit
seinem stethoskop um den ganzen haufen
herum und surft von corona welle zu
welle also mit anderen worten superstaat
ich weiß jetzt nicht so genau wie das
weitergehen soll aber wenn es so
weitergeht alle achtung
wie ist ihr fazit 100 tage angst
na ja ich würde jetzt nicht die ampel
daran messen ob sie das programm oder
die lieblingsprojekte von bild oben
setzt damit sind sie auch nicht im
gespräch ist verstehe dass sie das
machen aber das war jetzt nicht zum
beispiel wichtiger maßstab für einige
wenn es nicht meine aber gut weil sie ja
irgend ein bisschen ja doch ich halte
sie zuallererst an dem gemessen was sie
selber im wahlkampf versprochen haben
weil das finde ich ist immer die
geschäftsgrundlage auch als angebot an
die sie wählen und eine meiner letzten
amtshandlungen als ich noch
bundestagsabgeordnete war bevor ich in
die berliner landesregierung gewechselt
habe als der koalitionsvertrag rauskam
innerhalb weniger stunden das sozial und
arbeitsmarktpakete zu sichten wo
sozusagen die versprechen auch umgesetzt
wurden sind und mir ist aufgefallen ist
im gesamten sozialbereich faktisch nur
zwei projekte gibt die irgendwie die
chance hätten ein leuchtturmprojekt zu
sein und was zu verändern das war die
kindergrundsicherung und das bürgergeld
bei beiden ist mir sofort aufgefallen
dass die aussagen sehr sehr verschwommen
waren und ich habe immer gesagt also
entweder ist das nur ein pr-gag oder es
wird wirklich eine verbesserung und
jetzt wissen wir inzwischen dass im
haushalt dafür nicht mehr geld
vorgesehen ist also insofern befürchte
ich dass auch diese beiden einzigen
punkte das dort sozialpolitisch nicht
geliefert wird und das finde ich sehr
bedauerlich weil ich in meiner arbeit
täglich erfahren wie groß das bedürfnis
ist hier mehr zu tun im kampf gegen
armut
vielleicht nicht so ihr standort an dem
sie die messen wird oder doch wenn man
sich etwas vorgenommen hat dann muss man
es auch halten und insofern ist das auf
jeden fall einen maßstab die frage ist
ob das projekt eigentlich jetzt noch
verfolgt wird die kindergrundsicherung
steht auf dem programm soll wohl
diskutiert worden sein wie man hörte
aber ob das priorität hat oder ob es
erst zur nächsten wahl hin kommt um dann
für bessere stimmung zu sorgen ist wohl
noch nicht ganz klar soweit ich gehört
habe und die bundesinnenministerium
haben wir ja in ihrer performance auch
schon hinreichend bewertet wobei wir
noch ausgelassen haben dass sie der
ansicht war wenn man gegen korona
demonstriert kann man das auch irgendwo
unauffällig machen man muss nicht alles
stören das finde ich für die hüterin der
verfassung auch ein interessantes
statement aber es fühlt sich alles
zusammen ich finde es nur ganz gut wenn
man so ins amt stolpert und holpert dass
die umfragewerte eigentlich einigermaßen
stabil sind und es jetzt nicht zu großen
verwerfungen kommt also die union und
die spd liegen nahezu gleichauf
in der wählergunst hat der ampel der
staat nicht geschadet das muss man
einfach ganz klar sagen offensichtlich
haben die leute auch andere probleme und
können sich nicht ständig um die
neurosen der regierung kümmern
ihr fazit 100 tage ampel also 100 tage
ampel mit blick mit blick auf die
sicherheitspolitik muss ich kann ich
zunächst mal zunächst mal festhalten
dass die ampel regierung gott sei dank
in den ersten 100 tagen
sicherheitspolitisch
keine großen fehler begangen hat also
nichts schlimmes angerichtet hat von
einigen dingen die auch im
koalitionsvertrag
standen in berlin zeigt man ja nicht
gemeckert ist schon gelobt ja
ich erwarte jetzt aber auch nach 100
tagen gerade zu den zu den positiven
dingen die wir dem koalitionsvertrag
entnehmen konnten nämlich die
wiederherstellung der hohe gehalt
fähigkeit der polizei zu lage
beispielsweise wo mir natürlich als
gewerkschaft sehr daran gelegen ist für
meine kolleginnen und kollegen auch das
vorhaben das neue bundespolizei gesetz
noch einmal mit allen befugnissen die
dann notwendig sind zur
kriminalitätsbekämpfung und zur
prävention noch einmal anzupacken das
erwarte ich natürlich dass das jetzt
auch passiert da hätte ich mir gewünscht
dass da er mal signale gekommen wären
unsere in unsere richtung schauen wir
mal vielleicht passiert das ja in den
nächsten 100 tagen
und ansonsten ansonsten ja wir haben ja
nun über die sicherheitslage in
deutschland und europa und in der welt
diskutiert die erwartungshaltung unserer
kolleginnen und kollegen sind sehr groß
und ich hoffe dass das auch irgendwann
einfach mal jetzt im ernst man muss
natürlich auch sagen es ist natürlich
auch ein verdienst dass olaf scholz in
der ihm eigenen ruhigen art den laden so
zusammengehalten hat das mag man als
opposition anders sehen weil man
natürlich jeden riss gerne nutzen möchte
andererseits ist eine gewisse stabilität
gerade in diesen zeiten auch einen einen
schon ein wert bei
angela merkel haben wir 16 jahre lang
gesagt sie müsse mehr erklären und sie
hat es nicht getan das hat sich olaf
abgeguckt und startet entsprechend in
sein amt der große wurf bei der
sondersitzung des bundestages war ganz
klar gestanden hat hat der spd
tatsächlich sogar ein umfrage aufschwung
gebracht dann ist er wieder abgeflaut
olaf scholz hat bis jetzt nicht viele
fehler gemacht er ist sogar obwohl dass
viele gar nicht sehen sehr eifrig und
fleißig er hat sehr viele termine
empfängt viele leute führt viele
telefonate und zur krisenbewältigung
das nimmt man draußen nicht so war das
muss man vielleicht zur ehrenrettung der
ampel auch sagen dass es nicht einfach
ist einen laden mit drei
unterschiedlichen truppen zusammen zu
halten wurde eine tankgutscheine
ausgeben will und der andere lieber mehr
windräder aufstellen das ist schon auch
klar also so viel
an herrn scholz ja ich wollte jetzt noch
ein bisschen die kurve kriegen
vielleicht kriege ich mal ein interview
oder so was
war jetzt natürlich auch dein fazit noch
aber natürlich mit blick von dir auf
russlands krieg in der ukraine
wie ist dein fazit zur ampel wie haben
sie sich bis jetzt geschlagen
eine außenpolitische und
sicherheitspolitische naivität wie auch
in den jahren zuvor ein totalausfall im
verteidigungsministerium frau lambrecht
die keine ahnung hat von
verteidigungspolitik und dort jetzt als
ministerin 100 milliarden euro extra
budget
betreuen soll wir sehen gerade wie das
schiefgeht ich wünsche mir in so einer
situation nicht frau lambrecht die nie
was mit militär zu tun hatte sondern
jemanden der sich auskennt für mich die
positive überraschung um auch mal was
positives zu sagen oder berbalk die
aussenministerin die sie sich wirklich
gemacht hat wobei sie sich auch nicht da
genügen durchsetzen kann das muss man
auch sagen ich fand es absurd wie sie
argumentiert hat bei der rede von
selensky dass das doch alles so richtig
war also man merkt politikern an wie
sehr sie sich dieser koalitionsdisziplin
unterwerfen und wie viele schritte aus
meiner sicht vor allem dadurch begründet
sind dass man bloß kein streit zwischen
den drei partnern anfangen will das
sorgt aber für eine gewisse blutleere
weil ich teile deine einschätzung zu
frau lambrecht aber wie es zu erklären
dass sie sich weiter enthält und
voraussichtlich auch halten wird
das kann ich nicht sagen wie sie sich
halten wird und ob sie sich halten wird
die spd hat sie zur ministerin gemacht
olaf scholz hat sie zur ministerin
gemacht dass hier auch vor allem an der
frauenquote muss man ja auch mal sagen
die er dort umsetzen wollte denn frau
lambrecht war ja eigentlich schon raus
aus der politik nur ich glaube man muss
sich dann jetzt ehrlich machen und sagen
wir brauchen jemanden der sich in dem
amt auskennt wenn wir die gefahr sehen
dass wladimir putin mit seiner armee
einen nato-staat angreifen kann also ich
fühle mich persönlich nicht sicher in
deutschland werden vor lambrecht
verteidigungsministerin ist frau kipping
fühlen sie sich sicher in deutschland
während frau lambrecht
verteidigungsministerin ist also ich bin
jetzt keine militärexperten das gebe ich
zu ich
wenn ich mich unsicher schule liegt das
ausdrücklich nicht an dieser personalie
sondern meine große sorge ist und ich
habe jetzt verschiedenste runden mit
militärexperten mir angeschaut und
sachen gelesen und ich merke dass es bei
allen ein ganz großes zögern gibt weil
niemand so 100 prozent weiß welche
handlung unsererseits welche handlung
des westens welche handlung bei putin
verursacht also ist sozusagen ein mehr
thron vielleicht mehr waffen liefern
führt das zu einem einlenken oder führt
das bei ihm zum weiterdrehen in der
eskalationsstufe und wir haben sie mit
dem
machthaber zu tun wie ich finde es nicht
mehr berechenbar der aber zugang zu
atomwaffen hat und der einsatz ist also
ein sehr hoher am ende in krieg und dem
womöglich deutschland beteiligt ist
wohne atommacht im spiel ist und man
nicht ausschließen kann dass auch die
atomwaffen genutzt werden also das ist
so das drohszenario mit dem mann zu tun
hatten das macht mir wirklich angst
finde verstehe das bild jetzt
zuallererst irgendwie über
verteidigungsministerin herziehen muss
aber das finde ich ist irgendwie der
wirklichen gefahr ja es nicht lassen sie
mich mal meine vorteile aus leben ist es
doch hier sehr reflexhaft wie wenn eine
frau irgendwie die verteidigung an steht
das muss doch bei ihnen seien effekte
negative effekte auslösen aber ich bin
ja auch im springen ich bin ja auch
nicht ihre sprechen aber ich finde
dieses risiko ist doch nicht in dieser
so nahe begründet sondern das eben sehr
viele und sind am ende angekommen ich
wollte sie aussprechen lassen schönen
abend noch danke an meine gäste heute
abend tschüss
[Musik]